voilà alex métayer alex métayer par
l'internet au théâtre du palais royal
ça se passe bien ça se passerait bien
bien alors vous aussi donc je disais
depuis le début de la soirée avec des
fils de militaire il ya vous il ya
charles berling vous votre père était
radio navigant lui oui il était radieux
navigant il était un personnage assez
puisque il était à la fois ce militaire
et il était à la fois cet homme de
théâtre qui l'a toujours fait au noir en
tant que militaire il n'avait pas le
droit de jouer un sale et gedo jour
toujours connu mon père en algérie quand
on était à alger blida constantine
je n'ai connu beaucoup plus souvent sur
la scène elsa faux nom un ex en euros
voilà c'est le nom de la société pour du
jeu les beaucoup plus connus comme cela
que au poste de pilotage
ouais c'est à dire que c'était un homme
assez extraordinaire qui a réussi à
mener une carrière double pendant toute
son existence à celui que vous avez eu
le virus du spectacle de la musique
évidemment un parce que je lis avec lui
vous emmener avec lui là où je crois que
la première représentation que j'ai fait
je devais avoir 10 ans et je n'ai fait
pour des militaires qui partait en
campagne
ouais alors vous débutez on part
accorder toute votre vie mais enfin
parce que je suis seul edf soit et donc
vous débuté à 17 ans que musicien de
jazz et vous faites-vous en fait vos
débuts de comics sur scène 175 oui aux
blancs manteaux alors on sait pas quel
âge donné parce que vous refusez de dire
votre âge beau jamais eu raison une
régression de coquetterie sécurisons on
est classé le palais ducal de la wii
alors bon alors montré encore dans ce
n'était pas à cause des femmes non
excusées 90 je suis je suis casé ah bon
quand j'ai vu que vous attendez je
couchais avec les femmes bois oui c'est
à dire que je peux dire que pendant près
de 2 de 10 en 10 15 ans c'est beaucoup
plus important de vivre une vie
romanesque
on n'est pas dans le sens pas non il
fallait qu'ils aient du romanesque dans
la mène et
je les ai vécus dans la vie avant de le
transposer après sur scène ouais non
vous êtes toujours fait passer la main
avant cette idée d'arrivisme de se faire
une place de voilà maintenant c'est fini
non maintenant j'ai un petit garçon qui
a 7 ans je suis avec une jeune femme qui
est plus jeune que moi c'est que
maintenant c'est terminé
oui il ya un temps pour tout mais à
temps pour tout